Earth's rotation is the driving force of
weather patterns
the tides are affected by the Earth's
spin
so if we were to accelerate this
rotation would we completely destabilize
the climate
if you increase the rotational speed by
0.45 meters per second our days would be
shorter but only by a minute and a half
you might not even notice the change I
don't know but even with this slight
increase sea levels would rise by
several centimeters or a few inches yeah
the water around the poles would migrate
toward the equator now if you increase
this acceleration to 45 meters per
second then a single day would be about
22 hours
[Music]
start to feel confused almost like jet
lag